[Music]
all right
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we
are continuing to talk about
thought experiments mostly drawn from
philosophy and what we can learn from
them and so we're not looking at every
single thought experiment possible we're
looking at the ones where there might be
some sort of practical upshot or
application and last week we talked
about what four of them or four four
families of thought experiments and
including the infamous trolley problems
so we're not going to go into trolleys
again today but we left a lot off of the
list that we generated
we didn't get to them last week so we we
thought that we would do another week
talking specifically about other thought
experiments that either we thought were
really interesting and had a lot of cool
implications or that other people had
pointed out to us in social media that
they wanted us to tackle
yeah uh so we last week we went over the
Ring of gaiji's the uh shipothesis and
roko's basilisk and if any of those uh
what's your whistle then definitely go
back and check those out yeah you want
to go back to the last show and listen
to that and with the roku's Basilisk
though if you haven't heard of it before
and you don't want to have worries about
some super intelligent computer down the
line making you do things and punishing
you for not doing things in the present
and don't listen to that episode don't
look it up right right
uh this is a what ignorance is bliss
argument here right we can actually
uh actually it's ignorance is is better
than Bliss it's like preventative it's a
prophylactic
ignorance in this case is not Bliss it's
the opposite of misery right yeah so
which which one do you want to grab and
Tackle first of the thought experiments
that we were gonna play around with for
for this episode
and let's do the uh teletransportation
Paradox okay yeah this is one that comes
up a lot in relation to Star Trek right
right because you have those
Transporters and and you know when we
watch the show this never really
occurred to me as a kid
um you watch the show and these people
are being
whatever the analyzed and deconstructed
and then a copy of them is being
produced down on the planet or something
like that and you think well it's the
same person but is it really the same
person
right
so I guess the logic of the the show is
that they exactly they analyze you Adam
by Adam and all the positions between
all those atoms and
just basically dissolve you and then uh
recreate you Adam by Adam perfectly at
some other location
and I don't know about you but that's
like at least immediately gives me the
feeling of I just died and a new me was
born you know I never thought about it
that way until somebody actually pointed
it out to me I think when I ran into
some some philosophical example of of
this discussion
um I was just you know when I'd watch
the show I'd be like well yeah the Kirk
just you know Pops from place to place I
mean in a way saying beam me up Scotty
because there's you know whoever is
coming bearing down on you and they're
going to shoot you maybe it's Klingons
or uh you know Gores and who whoever
um you're you're committing suicide by
getting transported right in in a sense
but but there's a perfect identity
between the previous you and the new you
the only thing that's not identical is
it's not exactly the same
bits the same atoms but it's the same
basic stuff right and we talked about
this a little bit with the the ship of
Theseus beforehand exactly piece by
piece we change things which is kind of
like we were talking about as Even in
our own bodies we piece by piece lose
ourselves and they get replaced by new
copies on and over time that we're not
ever the same person
that this is just kind of like a rapid
that it's it's all in one
yeah and so you know we can we can think
about this by analogy to other cases
where we reproduce things and we don't
say it is the same thing right we we say
it's a copy of it so if I'm being
transported in this way
it's it is me in a sense it's me derived
you could say but it's not me in the
sense of the original me and I guess the
question that we should ask is well if
you maintain some sort of continuity of
Consciousness where like your your
conscious states are the same thing
coming out of the other side of the
replicator as they are when you're
entering it does it really matter does
it does it you know is this in the way
like of like living extra of having
additional lives I mean we could think
about it in terms of like games right
where you're playing a video game and
remember how like older games you know
you could only like save at certain
points and if you got killed you had to
go back to your now they call it a spawn
point I don't remember what we called it
back in the days of Atari the beginning
of the level yeah exactly yeah so if you
I mean you're almost always at the
beginning of whatever level you are and
if you're being replicated in that way
right and so once again this comes back
to a question of identity are you the
actual physical bits of yourself or are
you something more and if you uh look at
you know people who talk about like
substance dualism and uh or or you know
functionalist if you think everything is
just a physical yeah and there is no
like for example Soul or something then
uh then
what are what are you is it just the the
patterns of your memories and the way
that you interact with your memories
you know it's interesting what the
substance duelist thing a so substance
duelist we should say what that is right
somebody who thinks that that you know
there's there's more than one kind of uh
thing out there we've got bodies
extended substance and then we've got
minds and minds are not reducible to
bodies although they could be connected
with them in the brain Descartes would
be a prime example of a a substance
duelist and he he kind of thought that
the joint was the pineal gland which got
bounced around by the animal spirits
almost like a joystick very implausible
things but you know he says it's quite
difficult to explain the union of the
the soul of the body but here's where it
gets really interesting so let's say we
do have a replicator of this sort or a
transporter or whatever we're going to
call it and we're going to put me
on the other side of the universe right
and we overcome all the problems that
are associated with faster than light
travel and all that sort of stuff
because we're doing a thought experiment
yeah so a substance duelist could say
well you know if you replicate whatever
it was that that mind was connected to
in a different place that mind just kind
of like Zoop goes over there and latches
onto it and there's a really great
um set of sci-fi novels by Philip Jose
farmer the riverworld series where
exactly that thing happens everybody up
to about like 2016 or something like
that everybody through history they die
and then their soul and I forget exactly
what he called the souls I think he
called them their Kai you know after
like the Egyptian thing these these uh
aliens called the ethicals who are
carrying out this massive experiment
they create a world you know I mean when
you're doing sci-fi you can do whatever
you want right so they create a whole
world and it's there's giant river that
flows through it and then they have
these people reincarnated
in these gigantic Chambers
and then released into the world and it
gets even better because every time that
you die in that world you are once again
sort of reincarnated into another
another like 30 year old version of your
body and
um you know you don't have any clothes
you don't have any stuff but you're
otherwise you're you're okay
um so it's you know there are a number
of video games nowadays that have
exactly that model oh really yeah like
uh rust is an example of it's an open
world uh
a lot of people are all playing this at
the same time you have Persistence of
whatever you build in that world as well
as the items that you acquire in the
world until you die and then you read
uh get reborn again but you're you're
born naked and you gotta go back and
like build everything up again I mean
Minecraft is like that too you know my
kids got me into playing that if you uh
do something dumb like you know fall
into lava or all that
your stuff might still be there although
if it falls in lava it's pretty pretty
much done but
um you you go back to I guess the spawn
point and you've got nothing left and
you got to start hitting trees again to
start you know making yourself tools and
all of that so
um you said this is based on a question
of identity
um where I mean where do you stand at
let's say we took you and we did a Star
Trek thing and we just I know we sent
you down the road to Chicago and you
you're there now is that still you in
your view
so I guess for the most part I hold a
fairly functionalist view of things okay
the least of the mind so like the Mind
states are equivalent with mind States
um and so
I would say that
the the most irreducible thing that I
would say from that perspective is the
the pattern of my memories and however
those are encoded right right as well as
the the ways in which I interact with
them and so I guess you could call these
functions or programs to use some other
language to try to
describe this the way that I interact
with the world based on the all the the
previous experience that I have yeah and
so and when you introspect you you can
also access those things too right right
and so I still have all those memories
there and so I I guess it would be the
the storage plus the program
um and so as long as those things are
maintained yeah then I would I would say
that identity is equivalent I don't know
if it would be the same but it would be
equivalent yeah I mean I I have kind of
a pragmatic view where I'm like ah it
doesn't really seem like that big of a
problem to me
um so long as I still have consciousness
of myself when I get out and more or
less the same stuff is there I don't
even need it to be like total identity
I'm I'm cool with it you know like if I
maybe lost a memory or something I'm
probably not going to miss it that much
you know I mean or if like you know
let's say a fingernail fell off or
something now if I get transported and
remember that movie the the fly
um Jeff Goldblum now if like a fly was
in there and I happen to have like a fly
head okay now now we've got a problem
but I would still say it's still me I'm
just I'm just screwed up now it's a it's
a messed up you know genetically
modified me but there's still a there's
still a me there but maybe I'm wrong
about that maybe but didn't he also have
star are having fly Cravings that's true
yeah and so I would say that that is no
longer him because he now has
fundamentally changed why wouldn't you
say it's him but with fly Cravings added
up because because he's still making
decisions and and still TR he's not
totally driven by these fly Cravings
right but we have so many Cravings of
ourselves are like just our our animal
Cravings it'd be really interesting to
see yeah what a a human mind would be
the devoid of our body
no longer this could make Star Trek much
more complicated right like every time
they go in the transporter they have
weird random thoughts that now they they
know a lot you know they had before and
now they no longer have oh I'm cured or
they they get in and now they've got the
desire to like smear peanut butter all
over their body you know once a day or
something
it's like the aroma is just overwhelming
it would create so many problematic
plots you know you could never really I
mean maybe this is part of it we do need
identity you know
um you know something I was thinking
about so imagine if you had a society in
which
this was like totally accepted like the
Star Trek society and everyone's like
you know you get out and people are like
if you were if you were having qualms
and you're like I think I died back
there on the planet now I'm not me
anymore they'd be like ah shut up we all
do this all the time it's not a big deal
right maybe that would make it easier to
accept that but what if you were in a
society where like they are like you you
must not do this sort of thing it's
messing with with nature or God and and
if you do it you are killing yourself
maybe part of how we approach these
depends on what the uh social Matrix is
like you know yeah you know what like
they might do it in the Star Trek novels
but I could totally see this type of
Technology
um starting a like an anti-transporter
like religious following or occult to a
certain extent oh because they'd be like
you're creating new human beings who
didn't exist before you're like taking
the place of God or something like that
or just the there
there's a religions there's uh you know
anti-suicide and so if they see this as
committing suicide right and uh then you
could see like okay well you are you are
committing this sin interesting stop
them but I want to bring this a little
bit back down to Earth because like this
is like really like sci-fi we don't have
this technology yeah but we can actually
use this to kind of investigate
something a little bit more closer to
home which is the idea of becoming
unconscious either through sleep or more
directly through
um when we are put under through general
anesthesia
okay
so let's say you get you get put under
for an operation or something and they
take some bits of you out and put some
extra bits in
um obviously there's a change taking
place and what is the worry there that
you've gone from being conscious and
having a certain configuration to to
another one or
yeah and and you don't even need to like
go under the knife
um because like our brain at least while
we sleep uh stores certain uh memories
that we gather from the day and sizes to
choose others to forget and so you are
fundamentally a different person because
when you wake up you have a different
set of memories than when you went to
bed
so there's a there's something like a
continuity problem I guess
I mean do you see it as a genuine
problem because for me I look at it kind
of pragmatically again and say so long
as I didn't like
uh wake up with a new set of of memories
about like who I am and where I'm going
and what I'm supposed to do I'm probably
okay
I guess it kind of comes back to that
like
um identity question again if if you
actually identify yourself with your
memories yeah then you would want to
hold on to all the memories that you
could but every every day you're
throwing away some of your memories what
so that's an interesting thing to say
um
why would you want to hold on to all of
them I mean given the opportunity to get
rid of some of them that maybe are
holding you back right if you say I want
to be a better me and I don't want to be
let's say you had some terrible trauma
and now you're afraid of I don't know
iPhones or you know microphones or ball
jars or something like that you've got
the weird fixation wouldn't wouldn't you
want to get rid of that I mean that was
oh go ahead
if you have the choice of how which uh
memories to get rid of I'd say
absolutely yeah
um you know if you've seen uh what the
Eternal Sunshine is mine
the whole idea is to remove bad memories
but that's apparently not how our brains
work like if you've got something really
traumatic your brain's like yes I need
to make sure that I know that oh yeah
and super hard codes that to make sure
that you never do that again so it might
be coded redundantly right so that if if
you manage to get rid of it in one spot
it's already backed up over here and
then that kicks in or
uh it's more along the lines of just
like the way that we usually store
memories are our brainstorms and our
memories for us that uh we're not going
to forget the traumatic ones just by
going to sleep okay yeah we may actually
relive them in our dreams right I guess
yeah I guess the there might be ways to
um because you move your your short-term
memories to your long-term memories
while you sleep and so unless you you
know you had something really really
dramatic that day and you somehow
figured a way to stop the transference
of short-term memory to long-term memory
yeah that would be useful
but your long-term memories would be
more definitive of who you are right
than than just what happened in the last
24 hours wouldn't it right
so maybe there's a question of like wind
it curates what things that you want to
make sure are in your long-term memory
what if you wanted to implant new
memories
memories you did of things that you
didn't actually experience but could
imagine I mean we know that we can get
people to believe that they saw things
that they didn't see you know because
witness statements are pretty unreliable
and you can easily guide people into
thinking things uh see the satanic Panic
of the 90s yeah so maybe I mean maybe we
could do that was clearly a bad thing
maybe we could do it for good you know
yeah
uh uh potentially I know there are
people definitely working on that oh
really yeah like uh implanting memories
um now the research that I've seen is is
rather rudimentally rudimentary and it's
for like I think at most mice or rats
and so they'll
upload to a computer chip the solution
to a maze and then they'll stick
electrodes into the brain into their oh
like uh I don't know the mapping portion
of the brain okay they can make it
through the the maze without ever having
to having gone through the mace in the
first place and at a speed that would be
indicative of someone that's already
learned right yeah okay well that's
interesting
so this is this is actually a good I
think jumping off point to talk about
um another thought experiment that um I
mean there's a couple we could do that
we could talk about the flying man which
is also about Consciousness but I think
the Chinese room one would be
interesting to hit on because we're you
know we're talking about the
possibilities of AI right and how you
know to go back to Descartes when
Descartes is considering how us human
beings are different from animals he
also brings up machines because he
basically views animals as meat machines
you know they they they're different
than us in that we have minds and he
says that the way that you can tell that
we're different than machines is that we
can do a wider range of stuff
whereas a machine really can't it's it's
pretty focused and a machine can't use
um words to signify thoughts and that's
exactly what the Chinese room thing hits
on right right and I don't know if we
want to bring in like gpt2
or is it gpt3 now which is what is that
we'll get to that so that's the one of
the new
um AI
uh models for writing text that is
incredibly human like there was a piece
in the guardian a couple days ago and it
says this article was written by a
machine oh I I think yeah there was
something that was written about that a
while back right yeah I think we
actually spoke about that a while back
uh okay
yeah but if you give it like a sentence
it will write an entire article based on
that sentence and the information it's
pretty amazing just in in the last
decade or so
um looking at predictive text it used to
be terrible just just abysmally awful
yeah and sometimes it still gets a lot
of things wrong I mean I saw a joke the
other day where somebody is like
um autocorrect I am never going to be
using the word ducking you know
an interesting somebody you know or if I
am you just you know I'll let you know
um but unless ducking is followed by
under yeah or ducking to avoid something
yeah it's really getting quite good you
know yeah and I think a lot of people
who are Skeptics about the capacities
for
um computer generated things to be able
to seem human
um they're you know they they probably
at some point have to say well this this
passes something like a Turing test and
and that's you know the Chinese room is
connected with the Turing test so we
should probably talk about about that
right because it's a little precursor
for it yeah so the Turing test is a test
created by Alan Turing one of the
fathers of modern Computing along with
um Von Neumann
and on the idea of the Turing test is if
you are sitting at a terminal
and you're interacting with someone else
typing in that terminal
um
can you as a human determine if that uh
the your interlocutor your your
conversation partner
um is a human or not and the the closer
you could get down to 50 50.
the the better your test is before the
better your model is and the idea is
that you'd introduce a computer in there
and try to get the computer to mimic a
human being sufficiently so that human
beings would say yeah I don't know this
could be a person right yeah I guess I I
could have added that you're out of the
terminal and you're you're expecting to
either be talking to a computer or a
person and you have to after the end of
the conversation determine if the
conversation you had was with a human or
a computer yeah and so we say that a
computer would have passed the Turing
test if it could fool enough people I
guess I forget exactly what the
parameters are it's about like 50 50 if
you can bring it okay 50 50.
um then like you're you're at a level of
you know a human like okay I have no
idea it sounds like a human it talks
like a human you know yeah so there's a
lot of interesting ramifications of this
so we'll get on those in a moment so
what is the Chinese room then what so
the Chinese room is a thought experiment
from John cirelli on who
um it's been a while I believe it is you
have pieces of paper
that are slipped under a door and
um you and they are written in Chinese
right and
um
the and you're not a Chinese speaker
you're not trying to so you're on the
other side so you were just past these
pieces of paper with Chinese written on
them and you have all of the
dictionaries and all the books for
translating Chinese perfectly and then
understanding all the content on these
actual slips of paper and then the
ability to then re-translate your answer
back into perfect Chinese that's not
what Cyril has oh Cyril says you don't
you don't have dictionaries you have a
whole set of operators that say when you
get a slip of paper like this you give
them this slip of paper so uh it I mean
it would be quite interesting because
what you're mimic mimicking is a native
speaker right right and so like they say
you know Nihao you know hello and then
you're supposed to say Nihao back right
and then if they ask for like you know
where is typical sort of like where is
the bathroom you know so the sort of
stuff that we have in learning things
then you slip on it it says like ah down
the hall and and to the right you know
um and if they say so it's just a whole
bunch of if then like if this
give them that yes okay and and you know
this was
for those who know their history of AI
this was back when expert systems were
the big idea that you would exactly have
like a whole list of things that would
break down into complicated if thens and
the idea was that an expert is just
somebody who's great at hypotheticals
and can arrange all these things and can
give you the right answer and as it
turns out that's not how we do AI
anymore right but no but not at all yeah
but in part because it wouldn't work but
but searle's point was that the computer
he was using this to model a computer he
was saying listen the computer doesn't
have any consciousness of anything it's
just spitting stuff back out to you that
you've you know uh you've programmed
into it to respond to these inputs and
so talking about artificial intelligence
is kind of a a silly thing because there
is no intelligence you you could have
you know you could have a monkey back
there who hands out the papers you could
have uh whatever you want right it
doesn't it doesn't have to be a
conscious human being
and so I don't know do you see do you
see any value to this one in terms of
what makes an AI conscious like what's
the difference between uh just
responding in the correct order yeah and
actually I guess being a conscious agent
that you're interacting with and so I
guess when you get to the point of
Consciousness then you have to start
thinking about okay what do we owe this
Consciousness see Cyril thinks you're
never going to have a conscious computer
you know um he's he's using this to say
all you've got are operations that are
happening and and you know even with the
Turing test going back to that I mean
what if you have a really stupid human
being who responds in weird ways uh that
are kind of idiosyncratic you might
actually think they're a computer you
know you'd be like ah this person
doesn't seem to be a
um a conscious human being you know yeah
and like two years ago I believe someone
made a AI for a Turing test that uh
pretended to be like a seven-year-old
boy
oh and so because it's it's easier to
model what you expect a seven-year-old
boy to say and say like I don't know
yeah that's stupid or whatever yeah yeah
um and then that one tricked a whole
bunch of people that guy I think better
than 50 and it's like yeah that sounds
exactly like a seven-year-old kid you
could also do like petulant teenager
right yeah that sucks not interested
talk to the hand
over and over again
so there's a lot of interesting you know
ramifications to this I mean we live in
a world so we're talking about
predictive text one of the things that
we've talked about it on the show a long
time ago was the Elisa program which was
one of the very early dos based programs
and it was supposed to imitate a
psychotherapist it would basically take
what you said back to you and say that's
very interesting that you blah blah blah
blah blah how do you feel about that and
it so it would interject a few things
and you know if you interacted with it
for more than a few minutes you'd
probably figure out that it's a computer
but as they become more and more
sophisticated couldn't we have AIS that
are so good at imitating human beings
that we we get tricked into thinking
that we're dealing with an actual person
like maybe we have feelings towards them
or
um from attachments or
That's the basis of the movie Her
uh getting attached to and I don't know
if I saw that one tell us about that one
um it's a
very Advanced AI on which is portrayed
as conscious in the the film
um and the main character
um eventually falls in love with this Ai
and it doesn't have a body and so it's
just like a voice in a oh that's being
projected through a small like cell
phone-esque uh device that has an
interesting
um and it's it's a very like slow pace
kind of melodrama uh sci-fi film just
thinking about what are relationships
with between humans and AIS what would
that be like
this is going to become much you know
much bigger issue I think in the in the
coming decades but but in the reality of
it there's
um a thing from Google I believe it's
called Google duplex which will book
appointments for you and so and so that
what that is exactly the Chinese room
because I don't believe that is to the
point where it's conscious
um yeah it has enough information and it
has the voice synthesis to the point
where it will call up and ask to make an
appointment for a haircut or a a table
reservation at a restaurant and it it
feel a fools the vast majority of people
that are taking the phone call from it
but because the the use case is so
narrow it has the ability to uh deal
with like that narrow use case of
expected responses so we should probably
expect that there's going to be a lot of
similar narrow fields in which AI can
start taking a lot of things over right
right and so you know for one that is
very narrow that is being totally
um taken over I think we talked about
this at one point before as well was uh
lawyers and doing
um all right yeah document review as
well as a law review of in preparation
for cases and they used to be very
intensive and human work and now we just
have AIS that scrub through giant
databases and pull out all the relevant
cases I mean similar things are
happening with um Radiology too you know
I mean you could you could still say
well it's not going to like put all the
humans out of work because you still
need a human to kind of oversee and make
sure but it's interesting when you're
when you're letting the computer do more
of the work you start to kind of lose a
bit of your Edge when it comes to how
you would do it yourself right
um I think about like the music field
right there's so many things where I
mean you can take a garage band and like
make your own songs but it's really a
garage band doing almost all of the
heavy lifting for that you know
so I guess you look at technology as a
replacement or is it a bicycle
that just
elevates and amplifies your own given
ability I was just I was just thinking
about that Meme that has the person
who's riding the bicycle and then sticks
the the stick in between the spokes and
the fall stuff it starts yelling about
everybody else being at fault yeah if
there's an equivalent of that there
when you're given a bicycle you know
well look at like one of the biggest
stars right now is uh Billy eilish
and uh she did all of her stuff like her
original album I think was recorded in
her bedroom oh really yeah like bad guys
everywhere and that was like recorded
with a brother in a bedroom that's
interesting because you can think about
um musicians who in the past like did
everything you know think about
um Trent rezner you know Nine Inch Nails
the industrial stuff
um he you know he's he's doing he's just
programming everything in and then
singing over it but I think he had a
studio to do that in it wasn't just like
in his in his bedroom right because the
pro the level to get to prosumer is is
lowering and lowering every couple years
what if uh computers get assigned the
tasks of doing this sort of thing I mean
we saw with Google they had what was the
AI thing that they had that was creating
artwork
um
it wasn't it wasn't uh it was deep so a
deep mind deep mind I was going to say
deep thought but I knew that was wrong
right isn't it
I thought deep thought was from
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy maybe
it was yeah but so anyway it I mean it
creates artwork it's pretty crappy
artwork when you look at it right but
but presumably it'd get better and
better why not why not with music you
know yeah um actually you should really
look at some of the new work that they
have and they will uh you you put a
Monet and then you take your uh a selfie
of yourself and now you are done in uh
style oh yeah interesting I I'll show
you later I have a um a photo of myself
where I took the the cover art from
Neuromancer actually the video game
romancer from like 1987 or something and
then overlaid that on myself and so
that's actually so you're not just stuck
with like a bunch of like filters
basically like you know some of these
these yeah notes that say oh well do you
like this we'll do you like that it's
you could take whatever input you want
and then add whatever else so like you
could say I want to make my cat look
like
um old drawings of dragons or something
along those lines
um it would it would still look like
your cat yeah but it would be in the
style whatever like artistic style that
you have okay
um there's other things for like trying
to merge to like objects together
um but that's the the Deep Mind is is
absolutely beautiful in my mind like at
least that whole uh family of AI
you mean in terms of the terms of like
the concept you're attracted to that
yeah oh yeah idea yeah uh yeah and okay
artbreeder is a website that has the
ability like I've been seeing they'll um
they'll take a photo and then they'll
take like a bust of like
um Marcus Riddell yes or Seneca or
Caesar or like all these old busts and
then it like takes all of the the skin
complexion of the the photo and it
transfers them onto the facial features
of the busts wow yeah it's it's great so
we even here we're Way Beyond just like
language right and past slipping little
things under the door and then shooting
other you know things out from under the
door the inputs and and outputs could be
really anything within our our Central
range
is still around
sir um yeah sorry yeah yeah he's he's
old uh
I I would love to see what his new
Chinese room is
what he I think he reprized the idea a
couple times at different points but I
mean this would be something good to to
hit on very very quickly and then move
on to the next lot experiment so I
mentioned that expert systems that's not
how people think about AI anymore
um how is AI changed so that it wouldn't
be like you know slipping things under
the door it's not it's no longer the
linear kind of inputs like that
yeah that's what we start calling
General AI because even neural networks
are usually uh narrow use cases and so
okay have narrow inputs and outputs
um but so people that are working on
General AI are like all inputs and
potentially all outputs so generally I
would be approaching the distinction
that Descartes was making and saying
listen computers whatever robots
whatever you want to have them be they
can be really really good at this thing
over here but they can't fool a human
for long outside of that context because
they can't do a whole bunch of different
things they can't like first cook for
you and then compose a sonnet and then
like book your appointment and then get
into an argument argument with you about
politics but but a general AI maybe
could do all that stuff right yes okay
and a lot faster than you and I could do
it
I wonder here's the last sort of
speculation I wonder if there'd be some
things let's say a general AI is created
like that and it can process way faster
than than we humans and we make it very
intelligent I wonder if there'd be some
things where humans want to interact
with it in a certain way and it would be
like
I'm not wasting time on that crap you
know you people do all this you like
arguing about politics for example this
is not going to go anywhere I would
rather spend my time doing that I wonder
if that would be a sign of intelligence
ah I don't know
prioritizing right yeah yeah
um that's practical reasoning yeah but
then like okay but now I have to deal
with them so how do I deal with them
yeah how do I keep them from turning me
off yeah yeah
um
yeah what experiment do you want to talk
about next yeah let's go a little bit
more
real and let's talk about the veil of
ignorance okay so coming from John
rawls's uh classic work a theory of
Justice he proposes to us that we should
imagine that we're going to create a new
society and we're going to create
rules sort of you know top level rules
for how things are are set up and
structured who gets to be in charge who
gets access to what and he says whatever
you are right now imagine yourself
behind a veil of ignorance you have zero
idea about any of your characteristics
so you don't know whether you're going
to be tall or short you know thin or fat
young or old all these sort of bodily
characteristics you also you know if
Race Matters in your Society you won't
know what race you're going to be
identified with you won't know what
gender you are you won't know what
neighborhood you're born into and we
know that here in America it really does
actually matter there's like a whole
project that Maps out people's likely
outcomes depending on you know what ZIP
code they're in uh was quite
understandable so all of that stuff and
you and he goes even further he says you
don't know whether you're going to be
religious or not and what religion it
would be you don't even know what your
desires will be you don't know whether
you're going to like chocolate it you
don't know whether you're going to be
into
um you know stuff that other people
aren't like you know maybe being into
comic books when when comic books were
frowned upon you have no clue and then
here's the the thought experiment well
okay how would you set up Society then
what would you what would you do and
I've actually used this a lot of times
with my students Raul says that you know
as rational people we would try to
minimize the danger of winding up in a
bad position and we would we would
accept certain constraints on how much
we might achieve so if you think about
you know a sort of typical American
ideological system we say oh high risk
High reward you know uh capitalism is
great because we can all be millionaires
and and we know we that's not really how
it works but there's there's so many
people who are like I'm willing to take
a chance and I'm I'm willing to accept
lots and lots of inequality and
Injustice because I'm it might pay off
well for me and Raul says well that's
totally irrational if you were really
behind a veil of ignorance you wouldn't
see things that way because odds are if
90 of the people are going to have a
terrible life you're in the you're going
to be that 90 you know so you better
make their life better and so when I
when I frame it to students I'll ask you
what do you think well how do you think
students respond to it are they good
rolesians and they're like yeah yeah you
know we gotta really make this fair and
if there are going to be inequalities
there's got to be good reasons for it
and they've gotta you know we don't have
equal opportunity
um
so I guess just assuming the age as well
as the country of uh yeah the kids that
you're getting at your classes on and I
I'd say that their first inclination is
to push against rolls
that's the way it used to be
interestingly
um now I think in part because we were
talking about this with social contract
right the
um the current generation of students
tend to think there isn't any social
contract anymore the American dream you
know if some people get to enjoy it but
you're not going to take us in like a
bunch of suckers like you did with
previous generations
um and and they're probably right about
that that's probably irrational response
given how the economy works and stuff
but in the past when I would teach like
uh Millennials they would be like I'm
willing to take the big risk I'm willing
to say there's like a five percent
chance that I'm gonna have the big house
on the hill and lots of people to boss
around
um and and you know maybe a 70 chance of
being in a bad position and I'd be like
really and they yeah of course why not
you know I'm a gambling type
um but the the current generation not
quite so much
well I guess I feel a little bit better
about the potential future of our world
if we can make it through
well it might be the case though that if
things get better for them that they
like shift back into that you know the
American dream is is there for everybody
kind of kind of idea and this is a good
question here this is a little bit far
afield is the American dream the old
American dream like I'm gonna have a
decent job that's stable a car a
refrigerator TV
um you know satisfactory relationships
with my neighbors and you know a modicum
of of security or is it like I my
American dream is I have to be almost
like celebrity status in terms of
prestige and have tons of money and lots
of income I think people have two
different American Dreams out there you
know yeah I think the
the ideal has been moving towards this
super prestigious American dream and not
the like just a a good life or like uh
yeah yeah not a a bad life I guess and
so the American dream is like you've
made it with a capital M yeah okay uh
you know you've got you know
four cars in a pool and you know a big
house and yeah
who knows
you know I'll tell you something kind of
funny my mom
um you know my dad died when I was 11
and so she started dating I think when I
was about 13 or so and
um some of the people she dated were
pretty you know salt of the earth types
some of them were kind of kind of skeevy
and and you know I was glad they weren't
around all that long one of them was a
really nice guy who owned a medical
supply company and I guess medical
supply stuff must have been lucrative at
that time oh it still is oh but but back
then you know
um when maybe there must have been a
huge markup even even then and this
guy's hobby uh you know like some people
they they buy a whole bunch of
rolls-royces and stuff like that his
hobby was collecting John Deere tractors
and like you know refurbishing them and
painting them green and it took us one
time to his he had like a like a
warehouse and it was filled with like
you know 20 tractors and I was looking
around at this stuff and I was like man
I mean some people like [__] jewelry or
this guy I don't know what his fixation
is but I'm not getting into it you know
this this does not seem like the sort of
thing that you really want to hoard but
it was his collection he was super proud
of it and you know
I guess that's one of the more benign
things you could do with your wealth oh
sure right yeah
yeah he wasn't he wasn't into like stuff
that would hurt anybody right
right
um I think there's another part of this
we haven't talked about is like the
access to
um potential power or position within
society and so another uh caveat is like
okay
um do you build a society in which only
certain people buy peer dense of their
birth or whatever position that they
find themselves is the delimiting factor
to
um access to uh getting certain offices
like you know legislation yeah executive
office you know this is a great I
mentioned zip codes right there's a
project out there and I'm blanking on
the name of it but it like goes down to
the maps and shows you like what
people's typical outcomes are as far as
like income and a whole bunch of other
factors for those particular I think
it's called the inequality project maybe
or something like that and you can also
do this with like school districts you
know think about how
um if you go to the wrong school where
where class sizes are very large and
there's a lot of discipline problems and
it's underfunded you're probably set
behind quite a bit right or or now with
um covid and doing things online if you
don't have access to a laptop you are
really set behind quite a few people you
you can do some of your things on on
your phone but you can't do all of them
MATC I'll mention Milwaukee Area
Technical College is has been you know
providing laptops to quite a few other
students precisely so that they don't
have to try to do their schoolwork on
their phone which I think is a really
wonderful equalizing thing that they're
doing so you know when we talk about
access to opportunity we often you know
equal opportunity people talk about like
formally quality of opportunity where
like well everybody can apply for the
job it's not closed to anybody it's not
like you're saying no Irishmen can apply
like they used to in the old days or
anything like that
um but we're not all on the same playing
field and so you know people I mean
they've shown things like if you have
certain ethnic sounding names your
resume might not get looked at the way
uh other other names will and so Rawls
would say we need to like you know
quality of opportunity needs to be at a
couple of different levels right you
have to you have to make it
substantively possible for people to
have equal access
yeah and and so I guess we've we've
tried a couple in our own Society here
to try like I guess
um affirmative action is one of them but
like yeah it doesn't it doesn't hit
where it could all happen and so it like
like you like try to like put your
finger on what is the I guess the one
because we always want one answer and
not like multiple answers because that's
that's too much
they're like okay well you got to start
up like at the the earliest point
because that's that's when things start
to deviate yeah uh but if you're
starting at the earliest Point well then
you're like dealing with their parents
and so if you're not helping their
parents then you're not helping them wow
that's a real chicken egg thing then
yeah exactly a certain point you better
be helping dead people you know yeah and
so it's really difficult but uh yeah it
is something that we should at least we
can't just throw up our hands at and say
well too hard
yeah and so that's actually that's where
this becomes quite useful you don't have
to like redesign Society in some weird
abstract way from the start and then
like go to people with the plans and say
this is what my rolesian solution is you
can like get into situations and say
well how could we make things more equal
how could we how could we open up more
opportunity how could you know and we
can use it as a device for empathy I
think too uh it's very helpful to say to
people you know who are dismissive of of
the challenges that other people face
you say well what would it be like if
you grew up there what would it be like
if you lived there if you encountered
these prejudices if you had these
traumas that that you had to deal with
fortunately you don't and sometimes
they'll say things like oh well I don't
so I don't really care in which case I
don't know that you can do that much
other than just keep going going back to
them but in a lot of cases they will say
you know oh yeah I I didn't really think
about that it must be quite difficult
maybe I I'm a little bit more willing
now to do something you know
yeah so do we want to uh maybe
try to hit the experience machine
yeah you want to get into it yeah well
try to
all right so so this comes from Robert
nozick the sort of great opponent of
John Rawls in political philosophy and
it was from Anarchy uh Utopia uh what
was the other part of that
um I'm blanking at it but we got a way
to present this fast so there's a
machine right and it's kind of a Sci-Fi
scenario Philip K dick has has machines
like this as well and you get into the
machine and
um you can program it to give you any
experiences you want now the experiences
are not actually being had it's just
stuff getting pumped into your brain so
it's not experience in the true sense
but but it's giving you memories of of
and it's giving you inputs that at the
time feel like you're doing that so it's
also blocking your output so you're not
physically moving okay yeah yeah you
just sit in the machine and you know I
don't know we could we could imagine
like maybe it exercises you a little bit
so you don't turn into complete mush or
something like that and you know you
doesn't all have to be like pure
pleasure you could actually program it
so like there's cycles of like things
are really good and then they go bad for
a while because that adds a little bit
more incentive to you to like you know
uh feel how good the good stuff is
there's there's a game like that in Rick
and Morty where the person loses
themself in it and um
they like they become a carpet salesman
yeah I know exactly it's like in the
first season and I can't think of the
name of it but yeah it was it's a
brilliant idea and it's like the
experience machine right except it's
it's only it's only at the uh Galactic
equivalent of Dave and Buster's yeah uh
blips and ships that's right yeah yeah
and and Morty loses sight of the fact
that he's he's in it and that's what
happens to you so the question that that
nozick asks is well so let's say you've
got a machine like this do you get into
it and you can even program it so like
it'll stop every two years and let you
get out and you know decide whether you
want to get back into it or recalibrate
it and he thinks that most people won't
go in it I think he's wrong about that I
mean what do you think
uh considering like the the life
experiences of a lot of people on this
Earth I I think you know if I could all
of a sudden be like a International Spy
Playboy or or you know president of the
universe or astronaut or whatever the
heck he wanted you could
do anything yeah you don't even have to
shoot that high it could just be like
I'm gonna be financially solvent
right I'm gonna have a good job where
people people like me and I'm not gonna
get fired for some some BS reason right
you know right
um and then you know a lot of people
live a life that does not have that as
its current like levels and I think
I don't know I think uh nozak has I
guess a little bit of privilege here
that he just doesn't know how bad it can
be I think that's right and he he says
that the reason why people wouldn't get
into the machine is what we really value
is having the experiences and doing
things you know like making making
changes and also being a certain kind of
person and then he postulates well wait
a second what if we had another machine
that would somehow address that issue
and so he talks about like a sequence of
machines so he says that one of the
things we value is like producing
changes in the world result machines or
results what if we had a machine that
would produce whatever results that you
wanted
um and that would you know be a much
bigger machine of course but would you
then get into the two machines you know
okay what if you could get into a
machine that makes you into the kind of
person that you think you ought to be
would you get into that machine
oh that's interesting because people
spend lots of time and money on
self-help to try to make them the people
that they think that they should ought
to be yeah
um and what I go into I don't know is is
I mean it doesn't even have to be a
machine right it could be like if you
could take a pill or if they could put a
chip in your head that would turn you
into a more generous person you know
right
um man
I
I might do that like I've got I've
worked on a lot of things with my own
um self in order to try to make myself
like a better version of myself yeah and
and it took a long time because it takes
a long time to change habits and to even
to recognize what you need to work on
right and I don't know that's like kind
of like just flipping a switch and all
of a sudden you're better and and if if
the end result is the exact same as the
the work that takes to put in and then
you get to start living your best life
then why not
I would say there's still like maybe you
you'd know that you'd taken it maybe
what we'd have to do is then you'd have
to flip the switch and then forget that
you'd flip the switch right you'd have
to have a reconstruction of like your
whole uh origin story or whatever it is
of you is the good person you know or
maybe they can just obviously implant a
montage of you doing all the work that
it took you to do it
yeah you can actually have this is where
we get to the Philip K dick stuff so
Philip K dick has a story called we can
remember it for you wholesale and it's
kind of like that right and so they well
it's the basis of a Total Recall yeah
yeah and and so it could be
there could be companies because Philip
K dick always has like people
businessmen who are doing things and
there's companies doing things so there
could be a company that's specialized in
making training montages but then after
a movie they're for you and it's a BS
story about how you became the good
person the challenges you faced the
incites you yeah
you know and I suppose so long as you
never knew
that you'd been tricked in that way and
that you'd chosen to trick yourself
you'd probably be okay with it the
question is would you be lacking
anything because of that would there be
anything
wrong with that and we can think about
this from maybe the Matrix point of view
like I know Kung Fu and they just
download uh skills into you yeah
uh and they don't I guess you know
who knows how would actually react to
you all of a sudden just having
knowledge that he didn't have a minute
ago or a second ago like if you walked
into a place and suddenly you could
speak a different language and recognize
people saying that those things right
right
yeah but now we're talking not just in
terms of like skills but like moral
capacities yeah um I think we we kind of
feel like those have to be in some
respect earned don't we
[Music]
I mean this is a big topic maybe maybe
this is one we actually have to take
into getting close to the end of the
hour yeah we can talk about moral luck
and you know how we develop our moral
capacities you know that might be a good
a good topic to get into okay and so um
obviously there's no practice this week
yes same practice as last week
um and so we're going to end it with a
couple words from Isaac Asimov
science fiction writers foresee the
inevitable and although problems and
catastrophes may be inevitable Solutions
are not
foreign
[Music]